Ce que j'espère faire pendant cet enseignement, c'est de clarifier les enseignements du Bouddha.
Partout où l'enseignement du Bouddha s'est diffusé,
il a toujours été reçu par une culture, à travers la culture.
De sorte que peu à peu, ça a été légèrement détourné de son origine, et ça prend du temps pour que nous soyons capables de voir tout ce qui est vraiment typiquement l'enseignement du Bouddha.
Il y a trois grands chemins qui nous permettent de recevoir au mieux l'enseignement du Bouddha.
La science.
Les neurosciences.
Le romanticisme.
le romantisme, et la psychothérapie.
Je vais essayer d'être très vite sur tous ces trois points et j'espère ne pas passer autant de temps qu'hier soir.
J'ai ici une définition de la science qui...
J'ai une définition ici de la science qui ressemble plus à une religion dans la mesure où elle présume de certaines choses.
Le mot scientisme existe en français.
Il n'existe pas en anglais.
C'est une sorte de croyance.
Et je veux citer le grand sociobiologiste E.O.
Wilson.
Il a créé cette nouvelle discipline qui s'appelle la sociobiologie.
C'est-à-dire comment la biologie affecte nos différentes comportements.
nos différents comportements sociaux, etc.
Dans son livre qui s'appelle Consilience, l'unité de la connaissance, l'idée de consilience, ça veut dire ramener ensemble
Il dit que tous les phénomènes tangibles, c'est-à-dire tout ce dont nous faisons l'expérience, le mot phénomène représente simplement tout ce dont on fait l'expérience.
des étoiles jusqu'au fonctionnement des institutions sociales sont basées sur des processus matériels qui sont réductibles en fin de compte ils sont réductibles même si la séquence est très longue et tortueuse à la loi de
En d'autres mots, de la physique, vous obtenez la chimie.
Vous obtenez la biologie.
Vous obtenez les gens.
Vous obtenez la société.
Tout ça, c'est basé sur des particules subatomiques.
Même la conscience.
Ce n'est pas la position bouddhiste.
Le Bouddha lui dit qu'il y a trois composants qui constituent un être humain.
Notre nature physique, notre nature mentale et le nirvana.
un élément du Nibbana, c'est ce qu'ils appellent l'élément, l'élément du Nibbana.
Maintenant, quand nous méditons, ce que nous expérimentons est ce que l'esprit nous offre.
Le contact entre l'esprit et le monde physique se fait uniquement à la base du sens.
Le contact entre l'esprit et les éléments physiques ne se produit qu'au niveau des bases des sens.
Et la séparation de ces deux-là fait partie du fait de déconstruire l'être humain.
tout sentiment de substance.
Mais l'esprit a sa propre énergie, sa propre forme.
En méditation, ça arrive, c'est très rare, mais ça arrive que le corps mental sorte du corps physique.
Quand ça vous arrive, vous ne pourrez pas en douter.
Comme je l'ai dit, c'est très rare.
Seul un de mes méditants a eu cette expérience.
Mais les gens qui ont eu cette expérience tendent à ne pas en parler aux autres.
Parce que dans notre société de science dure,
les gens croiront probablement que vous avez eu un déclin psychotique.
Une science dure.
Les gens vont croire que vous avez eu un déclin psychotique.
Et les gens me disent
Une femme m'a dit qu'elle sortait de son corps régulièrement.
N'oubliez pas que de votre point de vue, vous n'allez pas croire cela.
Mais c'est toujours bon de garder l'esprit ouvert.
C'est toujours bon de ne pas arriver à une conclusion.
J'étais dans un train et certains fans de rugby sont arrivés dans le train.
Ils avaient bu un petit peu trop.
Ils étaient assis juste en face de moi.
L'un d'entre eux m'a demandé, « Est-ce que vous êtes un moine bouddhiste ?
» J'ai répondu, « Oui, je l'ai.
»
Et il m'a dit, je ne crois pas en la réincarnation.
Je lui ai dit, qu'est-ce que tu en sais ?
Vous le savez que par votre expérience personnelle.
Il m'a dit, non, non, il m'a dit, non, il m'a dit, pourquoi venir à une conclusion ?
Alors pourquoi vous arrivez à cette conclusion ?
Parce que vous n'en avez pas fait l'expérience.
Et son ami lui a répondu, mais oui, effectivement, pourquoi tu arrives à des conclusions ?
Donc, tout ce que vous entendez ici, gardez l'esprit ouvert.
Peut-être que c'est vrai, peut-être que non.
Ce scientifique dont on a parlé est un agnostique.
Quand il s'agit de Dieu, il n'a pas encore pris sa décision.
Ils ne peuvent pas trouver comment les processus chimiques produisent
Il y a encore un souci avec tous ces scientifiques, c'est qu'ils n'arrivent pas à découvrir comment tous ces éléments chimiques produisent notre vie interne.
Ils ne savent pas comment le monde physique objectif
se transforme en un monde interne subjectif.
Il y a un essaye très intéressant par un philosophe qui s'appelle Nagel qui est lui-même un matérialiste scientifique.
Il s'appelle « Qu'est-ce que ça a l'air d'être un chat ?
»
A quoi ça ressemble d'être une chauve-souris ?
Une chauve-souris vit uniquement d'après les sons qu'elle entend.
Ça s'appelle le problème dur en science.
Et un autre philosophe appelé David Chalmers
un autre philosophe qui s'appelle David Chalmers, il est arrivé avec ce qu'il pense être une solution.
Il pense que la conscience fait complètement partie du monde.
En d'autres mots, il y a de la matière, de l'énergie électromagnétique, etc., à la base du monde, et il y a la conscience.
Donc il y a la matière, il y a l'énergie électromagnétique, etc., etc., et il y a la conscience.
Now, he's getting very close to... Oh, what's the phrase they use?
Creation, intelligent creation.
Is that the word?
Thank you.
Intelligent design.
Donc il se rapproche beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle le dessin intelligent.
Donc nous nous retrouvons au panthéisme.
Où il y a un Dieu ou une conscience qui sature l'univers et qui le dirige.
Il ne va pas aussi loin que ça.
Vous pouvez le voir sur TED.
Vous connaissez les paroles de TED ?
Si quelqu'un veut ces liens, je peux vous les envoyer.
Dans le bouddhisme, le esprit est une forme d'énergie séparée.
Et vous pouvez dire que c'est
saturé avec cette forme plus difficile d'énergie que nous appelons les particules subatomiques et la conscience est juste une partie de ces 5 agrégats qui constituent l'être humain donc la première est notre physicalité
Le premier de ces cinq agrégats c'est le côté physique.
Le second c'est tous les ressentis ou les sensations que nous avons dans le corps.
Des sensations ou des ressentis qui sont causés à la fois par le corps et par l'esprit ou le cœur.
Toutes nos perceptions et nos concepts
c'est la partie la plus fine de notre esprit la partie qui pense, qui imagine et toutes nos habitudes qui incluent tout cela mais c'est une construction qui est dans nous et qui est créée par nous le corps
Le processus de ressenti, de perception, est apporté, nous est offert, nous est donné avec le corps.
Mais ces sankaras, ces conditionnements volontaires, sont créés par nous.
Et nous sommes un recueil, un ensemble, une collection de ces habitudes.
Dans la psychologie bouddhiste, on commence par une action.
Si vous refaites cette action souvent, vous créez une habitude.
Si on met toutes ces habitudes ensemble, on a une personne ou une personnalité.
Et c'est ça qui vous entraîne vers votre destinée.
On reviendra à cela quand on parlera de la moralité.
Il y a un autre problème qui a été résolu assez récemment, je pense, dans le domaine de la biologie.
Les biologistes commencent maintenant à voir que l'être humain est juste une collection d'algorithmes.
Maintenant, je suis seulement arrivé à ce mot, algorithme,
avec Google.
Tout le monde disait que Google avait un algorithme incroyable.
Donc, pour moi, c'était un vrai mystère.
Jusqu'à ce qu'il m'ait expliqué que l'algorithme est juste un nom, un nom flash pour un processus.
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un m'explique qu'un algorithme c'est juste un joli mot pour dire un processus par exemple quand on parle de pain il y a tout un processus pour arriver jusqu'au pain on appelle ça une recette ensuite on crée des machines pour faire du pain
Et on programme la machine pour faire le pain.
Et on appelle ça un algorithme.
L'algorithme, c'est juste la recette.
Excepté qu'elles deviennent de plus en plus fines, subtiles, intelligentes.
Et donc il semblerait que grâce à l'erreur
L'évolution moderne des techniques, ces algorithmes peuvent se corriger eux-mêmes et grandir et se développer.
Ils sont capables de battre des champions d'échecs.
Il va falloir se prosterner devant les algorithmes maintenant.
Cela présente un problème d'un point de vue de l'évolution.
ça présente un problème sur le plan de l'évolution parce que si nous sommes juste un ensemble d'algorithmes vous voyez votre ami être attaqué ou mangé par un lion tous vos algorithmes commencent maintenant à apprendre de cela et vous voyez les lions comme dangereux
tous vos algorithmes commencent à prendre quelque chose de cette situation et dorénavant vous verrez les lions comme quelque chose de dangereux donc la prochaine fois que vous verrez un lion vous courrez dans la direction opposée alors pourquoi avons-nous besoin de la conscience ?
c'est un gros problème ils semblent maintenant avoir un gros problème avec la conscience parce que ce n'est pas nécessaire pour l'évolution
On semble avoir maintenant un gros problème avec la conscience parce qu'il semblerait qu'elle ne soit pas nécessaire à l'évolution.
Cette façon de penser ne devrait pas nous être trop étrangère.
Les animaux ont passé des moments bien difficiles à cause de la culture occidentale.
La culture chrétienne.
Peut-être musulman aussi, je ne sais pas.
Saint Thomas Aquinas, le grand philosophe du Moyen-Âge, a dit que les animaux n'avaient pas d'âme.
Et la Bible nous dit qu'ils ont été créés pour notre bénéfice.
Il y a une histoire apocryphale sur Sarah Palin.
elle était sur le point d'être vice-présidente des Etats-Unis il y a quelque temps elle a dit si Dieu n'avait pas voulu que nous ne marchions pas d'animaux il ne les aurait pas fait sortir de la viande
ensuite Descartes a dit que les animaux n'avaient aucun ressenti et selon Newton les animaux n'étaient que des machines
Donc, au XVIIe siècle, personne ne s'inquiétait au sujet de faire des expériences sur les animaux vivants, par exemple.
L'idée que les animaux ne ressentent rien, ne vivent rien ?
elle se retrouve dans l'idée d'un être humain qui n'est qu'une série d'algorithmes qui ne serait qu'une série d'algorithmes donc il semble que de différentes directions la science s'oppose à cette notion de conscience
Du point de vue du Bouddhisme, il n'y a aucun problème avec la conscience.
Le Bouddha a parlé d'un corps fabriqué par l'esprit.
Et quand nous mourons, c'est ce qui laisse ce corps physique.
Et quand on meurt, c'est ça, cet esprit, cette conscience qui quitte le corps physique.
Malheureusement, les mots que nous employons pour ce type d'être sont très mal vus en Occident.
Comme « ghost » et « spirit ».
des mots comme les esprits, les fantômes.
Mais encore une fois, je connais des gens qui ont vécu ces choses, et c'est à vous de garder votre esprit ouvert, de ne pas arriver à une conclusion.
Le deuxième gros problème est l'éthique.
Parce que tout est conditionné, tout est un processus de ces algorithmes, etc.
Dans la mesure où tout est un processus d'algorithme, il n'y a pas d'espace pour la liberté, le libre arbitre.
Vous avez certainement entendu de ces expériences qui ont été faites pour montrer qu'on prend des décisions avant même d'en être conscient.
D'un point de vue buddhiste, c'est ce qu'on appelle l'insouciance.
Du point de vue du bouddhisme, ça s'appelle manque d'attention, tout simplement.
On a prouvé, ne serait-ce que ces jours-ci, en méditant, qu'on peut être conscient d'un désir à l'instant où il apparaît.
Et au fond, je n'ai pas vraiment envie d'être conscient de toutes mes décisions.
Je n'ai pas envie de faire une grande décision
Every time I open and close a door.
I mean, there are some things I would like to be automatic.
Even my waving my hand around in the air like this is unconsciously... is unconscious.
Anyway, this is Einstein.
A man's actions are determined by necessity external and internal so that in God's eyes he cannot be responsible anymore that an inanimate object is responsible for the motions it goes through
Il ne sera pas plus responsable qu'un objet inanimé peut être responsable des mouvements qu'il anime.
Ce n'est pas du bouddhisme.
Il n'y a pas de libre-arbitre dans le Bouddha Dharma.
La notion de libre-arbitre vient de Saint Augustin.
Dans le christianisme, le problème, c'est qu'on a dit que Dieu a été créé, nous a créés pour que nous l'aimions.
À quoi ça sert de créer quelqu'un que vous avez conditionné à vous aimer ?
C'est pour ça qu'on a dit que nous avions un libre arbitre de sorte que nous pouvions volontairement aimer Dieu.
Et là ça prouve que vraiment on aime Dieu.
Donc l'idée de libre arbitre dans notre mentalité occidentale c'est quelque chose qui est libre de tout conditionnement.
C'est arrivé très fort avec les hippies.
Je fais ce que je veux, quand je veux, à la manière.
T'es Claude François.
et à partir de là il y a eu un sentiment d'individualité très fort qui est né en Occident qui les gens de l'Ouest n'ont pas
Un sentiment d'individualité que les gens n'ont pas en Orient.
Les Indiens, les Chinois ne pensent pas du tout comme nous.
Pour eux, la notion de nous est beaucoup plus développée que la notion de moi.
Et dans le Bouddha Dhamma, il n'y a pas de libre arbitre.
Ce qu'on a, c'est le discernement.
Avec ce discernement, on peut voir qu'il y a des choses que nous faisons qui causent de la souffrance et d'autres qui ne causent pas de souffrance.
Et ainsi, on voit de plus en plus clairement la voie qui mène à la fin de la souffrance, de toutes les souffrances.
C'est comme quand on va marcher dans la montagne.
On a une carte et on suit la carte.
Et quand on arrive à un croisement, on vérifie sur la carte.
Parce que vous savez où vous allez.
Et parfois vous prenez une tournée fausse.
Parfois on se trompe, on tourne du mauvais côté, puis on s'en rend compte, on revient.
Il n'y a pas de libre-arbitre, mais il y a un choix.
Mais le choix est un faux choix.
Parce que si vous choisissez quelque chose qui est faux, ça vous prend à la souffrance.
Ce n'est pas juste.
Vous allez souffrir.
Quand vous souffrez vraiment beaucoup, vous allez chercher un cours de vipassana.
Et là, vous commencez à prendre les bonnes décisions.
Et ça vous amène à votre destination.
Qui est la fin de la souffrance.
Donc il y a un certain sentiment de choix, mais pas de libre indétre.
Il y avait différents enseignants à l'époque du Bouddha, six.
que le Bouddha a mentionné souvent en disant qu'il n'avait pas tout à fait bien saisi la réalité.
Donc il y en a un qui était matérialiste qui disait quand on meurt, on meurt, donc tant qu'à faire, autant avoir un bon moment, cela court les douze, tant qu'on est en vie.
Et nous l'avons aussi en grec, n'est-ce pas ?
Le matérialisme, le démocrate, je pense.
Le matérialisme dans la philosophie grecque existe aussi.
Il y en a un autre qui était un fataliste.
La vie était prédestinée par le karma, on ne pouvait rien y faire.
Même vos choix sont prédestinés.
On est conditionnés.
Et donc, tout est au-delà de notre contrôle.
Calvin dit à peu près la même chose.
Prédestination.
Ce n'est pas la position du Bouddha.
Ce qui nous aide à faire des décisions morales est notre sens de
Ce qui nous permet de faire des décisions de type morale, éthique, c'est le sentiment que nous avons de culpabilité ou de honte.
La culpabilité, c'est le premier geste vers la compassion.
Quand on se sent coupable, c'est parce qu'on a réalisé qu'on a blessé quelqu'un.
Et ça devrait vous mouiller vers la réconciliation.
Et ça a tendance à nous entraîner vers la réconciliation.
La honte, c'est plutôt lié à l'estime que nous avons de nous-mêmes.
Et quand vous avez fait quelque chose, vous avez l'impression que vous n'êtes pas à la hauteur de vos propres attentes.
C'est un enseignement pour nous apprendre à mieux nous comporter.
il y a beaucoup de problèmes autour de la culpabilité et de la honte quand ça devient des problèmes neurotiques on ne va pas rentrer là-dedans ça c'était le scientisme ils ont un problème avec la conscience que le bouddhisme n'a pas
Ils ont aussi un problème avec l'éthique en tant que telle.
Donc j'espère que vous voyez la différence entre ce que le Bouddha a enseigné et ce que le scientisme enseigne.
Maintenant, quand il s'agit de la science, il ne devrait pas y avoir de confusion entre cela et les enseignements des Bouddhas.
S'il y a une disjonction là-bas, c'est probablement le bouddhisme qui l'a fait mal.
Je sais, mais pas de science pure, pas de science vraie.
Le scientisme, c'est des présomptions qui sont nées de différentes expériences qui ont été faites.
C'est un autre isme, une autre croyance.
Mais la science elle-même, avec ses expériences directes qui peuvent être prises,
Mais la science elle-même, avec ses expériences directes qui peuvent être prouvées, si le bouddhisme dit quelque chose d'autre, c'est que c'est le bouddhisme qui est tort.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Heureusement, ce n'est pas dans les discours du Bouddha.
C'est dans les commentaires.
Dans les commentaires, ils disent que le Bouddha savait tout.
Et il savait que le monde était plat.
Et il y a des personnes qui le croient.
Ils ont mis les mêmes mots dans la bouche du grand chef du mouvement Jain de l'époque, Niganta.
Le Bouddha, lui, n'a qu'un seul objectif, nous libérer de la souffrance.
On va parler maintenant du romantisme.
Le romantisme a été une réaction à la période du philosophe Kant qui était rationnel.
et qui disait que les ressentis, les sentiments n'avaient aucun intérêt et ce rationalisme allait bien avec la façon mécanique dont Newton voyait le monde et les nouvelles façons de production avec la machinerie ont aliené le travailleur de ce qu'il produisait
Et la nouvelle industrie avec les machines et tout ça, ça éloignait le travailleur de l'objet qu'il produisait.
Tout ça, ça a été bien vu par Marx.
La réaction, ça a été ce romanticisme.
Et c'était principalement les Allemands qui ont développé une philosophie autour de ça.
Vous pouvez connaître Novalis et Schleiermacher.
Je ne les connaissais pas avant de les avoir le tout récemment.
Eux, ils ont dit que l'univers était un tout organique.
Ça ressemble à quelque chose de très moderne.
En fait, ça remonte à cette époque du romantisme.
Et s'il y a un Dieu, il est à l'intérieur de l'univers.
C'est plus comme du panthéisme.
Ils ne croyaient pas forcément en Dieu.
Mais ils admiraient la science.
Mais ils voulaient revenir à la nature pour aller au-delà de cette alienation.
Et l'expérience spirituelle la plus élevée qu'on pouvait avoir c'était de se sentir un avec la nature.
Être absorbé dans sa beauté.
Et cette absorption serait meilleure le plus vous l'apprenez.
Et plus on pratiquait cela, plus on était absorbé.
Et ça nous permettait de voir à quel point la nature était sublime.
On arrivait à voir la beauté dans la chose la plus simple, comme une fleur, une feuille.
Et parce que nous étions dans la nature, nous étions dans la nature,
ce sentiment de séparation disparaît.
Donc c'était leur expérience la plus élevée qu'on puisse faire.
Et ils croyaient, ces personnes particulières croyaient qu'il y avait une raison pour l'univers, qu'il allait quelque part,
Et donc ces deux romantiques disaient qu'il y avait une raison à cet univers, que cet univers se dirigeait quelque part.
Nous, nous ne pouvions pas savoir où ça allait.
Nous faisons partie de ce processus donc nous ne pouvons pas savoir où ça va.
Donc la souffrance la plus profonde c'était de ne pas être, de faire partie, de ne pas faire partie de ce processus.
Il n'y avait pas de moyen particulier d'obtenir cette unité avec la nature.
Il fallait trouver, chacun devait trouver sa façon de faire.
Et comme on faisait partie d'un univers organique, on n'avait pas de choix là.
Donc on fait partie de cette causalité qui a créé l'univers et dont on fait partie nous de manière organique.
Maintenant, la confusion pour les Ouestens est de penser que
Parfois, dans le bouddhisme, il y a cette erreur de croire que le Bouddha a dit qu'il y a une interconnection entre l'univers et nous, que nous faisons cas avec l'univers.
Mais il n'y a rien qui dit cela dans les Écritures.
Non.
La connexion, c'est au niveau de l'éthique.
Ah.
Il dit que nous créons une bonne ou une mauvaise société selon la façon dont nous nous comportons.
Le but n'est pas de créer une société, ça se produit naturellement.
Le but c'est de purifier notre propre cœur.
Est-ce que cela veut dire qu'on ne peut plus apprécier la nature ?
Le processus de libération ne nous arrête pas d'apprécier les choses, d'apprécier la vie, d'apprécier l'autre.
Comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure, le processus de la libération de la souffrance ne nous empêche pas de profiter, d'apprécier les belles choses, la nature, la vie, les relations humaines.
Il y a un passage dans les Écritures où on dit que le Bouddha est allé quitter sa nourriture avec Ananda, son assistant.
Et il dit à lui,
Laissez-nous aller à ce beau château ou à ce beau château pour manger notre nourriture.
Donc, ce n'est pas comme si le Bouddha n'était pas conscient de ce qui était beau ou qu'il n'appréciait pas ce qui était beau.
Mais l'objectif de notre pratique n'est pas d'être à l'un avec la nature.
Et le but de notre pratique n'est pas de faire un avec la nature.
Mais si cette expérience nous arrive, c'est très bien.
Ce n'est pas le but, simplement.
Et à nouveau, on se retrouve avec le problème de l'éthique.
Qui ressemble souvent à quelque chose de fataliste ou de prédestiné.
Mais l'enseignement du Bouddha est que notre éthique est basée sur une mauvaise compréhension des choses.
Non, je n'ai pas bien exprimé ça.
Notre comportement est souvent basé sur une mauvaise compréhension des choses.
Notre comportement est souvent basé sur une mauvaise compréhension.
La moralité dont nous faisons preuve, c'est une expression de notre sagesse ou de notre manque de sagesse.
C'est pourquoi l'éthique est vraiment au cœur de l'enseignement du Bouddha.
Parce que par la façon de l'éthique, nous revenons à l'origine
Parce que grâce à l'éthique, à l'observation de la vertu, on arrive à l'erreur originale.
Et l'erreur originale, elle se trouve dans le sentiment que nous avons d'être quelqu'un.
Ce sentiment d'être une personne, c'est quelque chose qui apparaît sur l'écran de la conscience.
Et c'est à travers ce sentiment d'être une personne que l'on entre dans le monde phénoménal que nous créons.
Et parce que nous croyons que nous sommes ce monde, nous cherchons
Mais le monde n'est pas crédible.
Donc on commence à collecter.
On commence à accumuler les choses.
On devient acquéreur de toutes choses.
C'est un bon mot pour gréguer.
Et plus j'ai, plus je me sens sain.
Plus j'en ai, plus je me sens en sécurité.
Si j'ai plus d'argent, plus d'amis, plus de nourriture, ça me donne de plus en plus le sentiment d'être en sécurité.
Pourquoi ai-je besoin de ce sentiment de sécurité ?
Parce que je sais que là-dessous, tout va disparaître.
Ah !
J'éloigne l'idée de la mort, de la disparition de toute chose, en réunissant beaucoup de choses.
Si il y en a d'autres qui essayent de prendre ce que moi je possède, il faut que je me débarrasse d'eux.
Et là, on a l'aversion.
Et si cette personne est plus grande que moi, je dois courir.
et si cette personne qui veut prendre mes possessions est plus forte que moi alors là il faut que je me sauve je me sauve en portant toutes mes possessions c'est la peur et donc l'avidité, l'aversion et la peur sont toutes ces attitudes fondamentales que nous avons à cause de cette erreur
Et tandis que les romantiques pensaient que cette absorption dans la nature était l'expérience la plus élevée que les humains puissent avoir,
le Bouddha lui avait des absorptions beaucoup plus profondes que nous appelons les jhanas mais il a dit même ça ce n'était pas satisfaisant donc le but était d'aller au-delà des phénomènes au-delà de l'univers et c'est le nirvana donc le troisième est la psychothérapie
Troisième étape, la psychothérapie.
Freud est très proche du Bouddha.
Parce qu'à la fin de ses enseignements, il a dit qu'on avait deux choses qui nous poussaient dans la vie.
Le désir de vivre et le désir de mourir.
Le Bouddha a souligné aussi ces deux désirs très profonds qui sont en nous.
Le but de la plupart de ces psychanalystes était de nous trouver à l'aise avec la vie.
On ne cherchait pas à la fin de la souffrance.
Je ne sais pas si Freud croyait dans l'après-vie.
Le truc, c'était de sortir les choses du subconscient et les amener au niveau conscient.
C'était ça qui était censé
guérir les turbulences en nous on trouve ça dans la méditation c'est exactement ce qui se passe on guérit les turbulences c'est plutôt le but qui est différent dans notre méditation on n'essaie pas de se psychanalyser ni d'essayer de faire sortir les choses
notre but est différent et pendant qu'on suit notre but dans une certaine direction le coeur arrive à se soigner de lui-là et aussi le behaviorisme et ça allait dans l'autre direction il semblait ignorer
notre vie intérieure.
Et qu'on pouvait finalement conditionner les gens à se comporter de manière bonne ou mauvaise.
Le bâton ou la carotte.
Si vous voulez que le chien s'envoie, vous lui donnez des carottes.
Si vous voulez que l'âne avance, vous lui donnez une carotte.
Et si il ne veut pas avancer, vous lui donnez un tap avec le bâton.
Et des gens comme Skinner pensaient que nous devrions être entraînés comme ça.
Et c'est vrai qu'il y a quelque chose de vrai là-dedans.
Chaque fois que nous faisons quelque chose où nous obtenons un certain nombre de plaisir ou de récompense, nous le répétons.
À chaque fois qu'on fait quelque chose qui nous apporte soit une plaisir, soit une récompense, on a tendance à le répéter.
Mais après, ça peut devenir addictif.
Et quand on fait quelque chose qui nous paie, qui nous hurt, on n'a pas tendance à répéter cette action.
Mais c'était un très... Ça a juste dénié votre vie intérieure.
Mais toute cette théorie dénie
Elle nie notre vie intérieure.
Et puis il y a eu le mouvement humaniste.
Là encore, il y a quelques-uns qui étaient assez proches de la compréhension du bouddhisme.
Mais encore une fois, c'était cette idée holistique que nos vies, vous savez, nous ne devrions pas nous inquiéter des choses subconscientes.
c'était une idée holistique l'idée c'était de ne pas trop s'inquiéter de tout ce qui est subconscient on doit se développer pour devenir des êtres humains complets donc l'école humaniste avait pour idée de se développer on devait se développer nous-mêmes mais dans toutes ces écoles ce qui manque c'est la transcendance
Ils comprennent l'éthique à leur manière.
Et leur présomption, c'était que si on arrivait à se nettoyer de tous ces traumas qu'on pouvait avoir, on était automatiquement une personne meilleure.
Et c'est probablement vrai.
Alors, où se situe l'enseignement du Bouddha dans tout ça ?
On a parlé un peu d'éthique.
Comment l'éthique apparaît de la relation que nous avons avec le monde dans lequel nous sommes.
Une des images que j'utilise est celle de Narcissus.
J'utilise l'image de Narcisse.
Si vous vous souvenez de l'histoire, Narcisse se regarde dans une rivière et il voit sa propre image.
Et il tombe amoureux de sa propre image et il veut s'embrasser d'elle-même.
Il tombe dans l'eau et il se noie.
C'est souvent compris comme un acte de fierté ou de self-fierté.
Mais spirituellement, ça fonctionne parfaitement.
Quand l'awareness intuitive se trouve dans la conscience de cet organisme psychophysique, quand l'awareness intuitive
quand la conscience intuitive se voit dans la conscience, c'est la conscience de soi que l'on a quand on médite.
Quand je vous propose de transformer tout ce que vous ressentez sous forme d'objet.
Et vous vous ressentez comme étant celui qui observe ou qui ressent.
Donc, ce self que vous voyez est l'image de cette conscience intuitive dans la conscience.
Ah, c'est son reflet.
Et ça va dans cette direction.
Et là, on rentre dans les eaux de la création.
Ah, l'eau dans la mythologie est toujours la création.
l'eau dans la mythologie c'est toujours une création et elle se noie dans le monde phénoménal le monde que nous créons donc le processus revient sur le bord de la rivière donc je vais juste vous laisser avec un ou deux quotes le Bouddha parle à
et des gens et il fait cette statement il y a quelque chose qui n'est pas né qui n'est pas devenu et qui n'est pas fabriqué si il n'y avait pas
Si ça n'existait pas, cette chose qui était non-née, non-fabriquée, non-conditionnée, on ne pourrait pas échapper à ce qui est né, ce qui devient, ce qui est conditionné.
maintenant, le mot qu'il utilise ici en palais c'est ATTI il y a deux mots pour le verbe être en palais l'un est HOTI et l'autre est ATTI HOTI est ce que nous appelons comme quand vous dites c'est un smartphone c'est juste de connecter deux mots
On fait le lien entre deux mots.
Tandis que Ati, ça veut dire ça existe vraiment.
Donc les gens, quand ils lui ont posé la question quand vous mourrez, est-ce que vous continuerez à exister ?
À ce moment-là, on a employé le mot Ati dans le sens d'exister en soi.
Il y a une description encore plus claire ici.
il y a une dimension où il n'y a ni terre, ni air, ni feu, ni eau.
En d'autres mots, le monde physique n'existe pas.
Les autres sont liés à ces absorptions internes.
Ensuite il parle des absorptions intérieures.
Les dimensions de l'infini, de l'espace infini, etc.
C'est toutes les dimensions des différentes absorptions méditatives.
Ce sont des niveaux d'absorption méditative très profondes où tout disparaît de l'esprit.
Il n'y a pas ce monde, il n'y a pas le monde après, il n'y a pas de lune, il n'y a pas de soleil.
Pas d'aller, pas de venir et pas de rester non plus.
On est en dehors du temps.
Il n'y a pas d'apparition, pas de disparition.
Il n'y a rien.
Non.
Donc les choses ne sont ni fixées, ni en train de bouger.
Il n'y a pas de support.
En d'autres mots, il ne s'appuie sur rien.
Juste ça, c'est le fin du souffrance.
Ça, c'est la fin de la souffrance, quand on arrive à cet espace-là.
Il y a des enseignants qui nient cet enseignement sur la transcendance.
Et je ne comprends pas comment ils peuvent le faire.
Ça vous crie à la figure, voilà, c'est comme ça.
L'année dernière, j'ai donné une émission, je crois que c'était l'année dernière, sur un nonne appelé Meichi Kiao, je crois que c'est comme ça qu'il le prononce.
Et elle est morte en 1991.
Donc elle est contemporaine.
Ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui vivait dans les âges médiévaux ou loin.
Et c'est...
Elle était un arahat.
Elle est complètement libérée.
Donc c'est ce qu'elle dit.
Le corps...
Le corps, l'esprit et l'essence sont tous distincts et ce sont des réalités séparées.
Absolument tout est connu.
Ça veut dire qu'on en est conscient.
La terre, l'eau, le feu et l'air.
Ce monde physique.
Le corps, les ressentis, les mémoires, les pensées et la conscience.
La traduction des cinq agrégats dont on a parlé.
Les sons, le produit des cinq sens et les émotions.
La colère, l'avidité et la vision erronée des choses sont connues.
J'en ai pris parfaitement conscience, telles qu'elles sont, dans leur état naturel, vrai.
Et peu importe à quel point je suis exposé à tout cela,
Je suis incapable de détecter, ne serait-ce qu'un instant, quand ils ont la force, le pouvoir sur mon cœur.
Ils apparaissent et disparaissent.
Ils changent tout le temps.
Mais la présence qui en est consciente ne change jamais pour un instant.
Elle est pour toujours non née et non morte.
Elle ne pourra pas mourir.
C'est ça la fin de la souffrance.
Donc là, il y a quelqu'un qui est né à notre époque et qui nous dit que la transcendance, ça existe.
Et ça, c'est dans cette direction que pointent tous les enseignements de Bouddha.
J'espère simplement que mes paroles ont été une certaine assistance, vous ont aidé un peu.
Je n'ai pas créé encore plus de confusion.
Et que par votre dévotion à la pratique, vous puissiez être libérés de toute souffrance.
De préférence au plus tôt qu'au plus tard.